listen congrats on season two of the
show I was such a fantasies and one and
I'm so excited that we're getting a
sophomore season Vanessa heading into
season two are your personal
expectations even higher because of what
we saw in season one season one blew us
all away and one of the issues we had
with season one is at that first cut was
so deep I mean we got rid of so much
talent after that first episode so I was
excited to see that we were giving these
next season two queens longer
opportunities to prove themselves so
that's what you see in this season and
again the the talent is varied the
countries are all over the world that
are that are interesting and different
with different accents different
approaches different body types and
different styles and I think those who
love season one will certainly be in
store for a great season two that's what
I love about this show is that it is so
inclusive and it is worldwide there is
no Canadian Canadian this season just
saying but
manifest to season three and have a
Canadian on there okay Michelle listen
you are tough you are a tough judge and
I love somebody who's tough and tells it
like it is because listen I don't have
time to beat around the bush in my life
and I don't think you do either but it
always comes from a place of love and we
know that uh would you say that being on
this panel you can be a tougher judge or
is drag race where you can really dig in
a bit deeper I have to say that I don't
make there's no difference to me judging
is judging I was the same on Ireland's
Got Talent any show that I judge on I
can only bring me to the party because
this is what I do I had a mother from
Brooklyn who you know used to tell me it
ain't easy out there kid The World Isn't
sugar-coated I'm not gonna play a game
you know when I was growing up I wanted
to be a veterinarian and she knew that I
wasn't going to hack it in the Academia
part of this world and she was like you
know that's 12 years of school and I was
like I know and then she said well
you're gonna have to put um dogs to
sleep and I was like okay I'm gonna be
an actress and she was like yeah do that
so for my mother to steer me away from
medical school and Academia to try to be
an actress or preparing this world it
was just the reality the reality is I
wasn't smart enough to probably get
there at that point in my life so I do
approach everything like that tough
mother love but um again when I audition
I want notes I want people to tell me
why I didn't get the job what I could
improve how I could get better that's
what the world is so that's what these
kids deserve and that's what I can only
be well you're fantastic on both shows
just not to say that I I appreciate what
you do and the advice that you give
because it always is really constructive
advice it's not mean-spirited somebody
take it as that but really you want to
see these people Excel it is not coming
from a mean place no we were saying that
earlier that
um some people will say that it's harsh
but it's only because they're faced with
the truth and the truth always hurts and
that's just the the end yeah listen
Trixie not to blow smoke up your behind
but you were like the epitome of what we
are looking for on Queen of the Universe
you are a incredible drag artist I've
told you that many times you are a
musician that I respect and love
um tell me Trixie what is the full
package for you and when you see
somebody on that stage if they don't
have the full package yet you know the
voice the look The Moves what is the
most important thing to you first and
foremost I think as a competitor like as
somebody who's competed in televised
drag competitions and now attends them
and gets to give my opinions nothing
will benefit you more in real time than
actually listening to the critiques
being given to you otherwise a year
later you have to watch it on TV and go
she was wearing they were right I was
wrong so in the moment when their usual
audience is gone their boyfriend you're
their only Lifeline to tell them how
they're doing so I really just try to
tell them what I think it will be like
when they're out singing in a wig
because I do that so just you know you
do do that and Michelle gave you some
advice during your time on drag race of
course what was the most important
advice that Michelle threw at you that
in the moment you might have been like I
hate that woman but now you look back on
and you're like damn she was right yeah
I never had anything but I mean honestly
I never got anything bad because at
least I I lack that drag queen Gene that
is like too much delusion by the time a
critique was coming down the pipe from a
judge I pretty much knew what like I
wasn't like what do you mean I was
incredible I was like here we go I know
exactly what they're gonna say and then
they said what I thought they would say
so believe me I was always the first
person aware of myself making mistakes
which I would say is a good place to be
because you don't want to hear critique
and go well that has nothing to do with
me bye which happens a lot which happens
a lot which does happen a lot listen Mel
B has joined the cast as a judge on
season two of Queen of the Universe I am
such a Spice Girls fan I think we all
are they were just one of the most
iconic groups and still are of all time
I'm gonna ask each of you this if I was
a spice I think I'd be beardy spice I
think that's pretty obvious so Vanessa
which Spice would you be I would say
herbs a Provence because it's a mixture
all the delicious fancy spices that I
use on my fish
Michelle what spice would you be all
spice
because you smell like a man oh
[Laughter]
I would be Stevia very sweet but
incredibly fake
listen season two is I got to watch some
I don't want to give any spoilers or
anything Trixie what do you think is
going to gag people the most about this
sophomore season well I'm just gonna say
what everyone's afraid to mention which
is the show has more money the the
pyrotechnics the dancers the costumes
the wigs the production that we enjoyed
on season one now it's like a hat on a
hat I mean right from the first episode
you get a show yeah so we have these
incredible artists being featured even
more yeah yeah listen congratulations on
this it was so nice to chat with all of
you Trixie we go back a few years now
but Michelle and Vanessa Legends icons
great to meet you both and congrats on
season two thanks Dallas
thank you